ASH SCHEDER BLACK: Tech up
level is a student engagement
experience in which
we hire students
on to develop software and
web-based applications for U
of A faculty or
administrative units.
But to do it in a way that
allows the students to learn
a tremendous amount on the job.
HAZZA ALKAABI: In a sense,
this is actually a very rich
learning experience.
I learned, not just
software skills,
it's more than, just team
skills, communication skills.
You hone all these skills.
You have deadlines that
you would love to make
and so you always
try to make them.
And that's why
it's exciting here.
ASH SCHEDER BLACK:
When we pull together,
we learn a lot faster.
We invent a lot
quicker, and we spread
the knowledge a lot faster.
It amazes me every day for
like the things that I can do.
And every day when I
solve another problem,
I'm just so proud of
myself because it's just
so amazing like the
things that I can do now.
It's so interesting how
everything works together
on so many different
levels to produce this.
It's amazing.